but you know when [ __ ] gets real is when  it's like oh well you're really smart  too and you're really talented and  you're gonna mirror to me all the ways  in which I'm operating in insecurity and  inadequacy and fear and scarcity and  what's in the way of me being fully  present and actually sharing and being  in unity and so that's where we're at  right now like that's where we're at  that's where the future is just like  right there ready for us to build heaven  on earth is already here you know but  that's the stuff that we get to tackle  together and I like to speak about that  really explicitly because it to me means  like this initiation and rite of passage  journey that new earth architects and  leaders visionaries were called to go on  together  [Applause]